[Applause]
[Music]
have you ever heard of Erbil despite
threats from Baghdad it seems probable
that geography students will soon have
to learn the name of this capital city
as well as its new country and that
would be Iraqi Kurdistan the 25th of
December this year was a historical
moments for the more than five million
Kurds who currently live in this
autonomous community in the north of
Iraq and well why was this well that's
because of after decades of unfulfilled
promises and ethnic repression they have
the opportunity to vote in a referendum
organized by the regional government of
Kurdistan since 2005 and according to
the constitution of Iran Kurdistan is an
autonomous region despite it being an
autonomous region though this place
essentially works as its own almost
independent country and the result of
this was that the population really
wanted to be fully independent
[Music]
the day of the referendum Kurds showed
up on mass to the polling stations even
the speaker's of mosques encouraged
voters to go to the polls while the
final results showed the referendum was
a complete success more than seven out
of every ten Kurds went to vote
that's almost 3.1 million voters the
victory well it was overwhelming for
those who supported independence the
movement is obtained ninety two point
seven three percent of the vote and you
know what well this tribe that's totally
understandable because we're talking
about some of the most ill treated
people in history they well treated
despite the fact that the Kurds are
according to many experts the most
ancient people in this entire region
[Music]
it is estimated that their culture their
language their rituals essentially
everything that could define them have
been in this part of the world upper
Mesopotamia for more than four thousand
years in fact many of these experts
consider the city center of Erbil the
capital has the oldest human settlement
to be continuously inhabited on the
planet
[Applause]
in other words the Kurds are bolder than
the Persians or indeed the Arabs however
they have suffered from all kinds of
persecution see the total number of
Kurds is around 30 million spread across
mainly four countries Turkey Iran Syria
and Iraq well in all of these places the
Kurds have suffered the consequences of
nationalism which has tried to make them
disappear as a community they've tried
to end their culture their language as
well as trying to close down their media
outlets between 1986 and 1989 Saddam
Hussein launched the am full of campaign
and estimations are the between 50,000
and 180,000 Kurds died as a result as he
might imagine this cannot easily be
forgotten my grandfather had a good
sense of humor he used to say that he
was born occured in a free country
then the Ottomans arrived and said to my
grandfather your ottoman at the fall of
the Ottoman Empire he became Turkish the
Turks left and he became a Girt again
then the British arrived so my
grandfather became a subject of his
gracious majesty the British invented
Iraq so my grandfather became Iraqi but
to his dying breath he was never proud
of being Iraqi he near Salim my father's
rifle a childhood in Kurdistan
considering the history it's no surprise
that the Kurds once once and for all to
make the dream of having their own state
come true and if we add up the fact that
Iraqi Kurdistan is quite a rich area in
terms of oil and natural gas as well as
fresh water by the way we can understand
even more why they want independence so
to some of the Kurds they wanted their
own country and so they held a
referendum in order to do that
[Music]
the referendum
as we have said Kurdistan is almost an
independent country already they even
have their own army of more than two
hundred thousand soldiers this army is
called the Peshmerga and they've by the
way been the main defense to Islamic
state in Iraq do you bear this in mind
because the government of Kurdistan is a
close ally of Washington indeed it may
be their most loyal ally in the region
because of this the US has trained and
financed and well-armed their army
so I'm indeed even saved that the Kurds
are as pro-american as the taxes
[Music]
so after many difficult years of intense
fighting against Islamic state it has
been clear for the Kurds there are
almost no advantages in remaining in
Iraq and the governments of a bill took
advantage of these battles in order to
integrate Kurd areas into their
political space for example there is the
province of Kirkuk who has a majority of
Kurds but was not within the autonomous
region of Kurdistan Kirkuk is something
of a crown jewel and one of the main
reasons for the conflicts with the Iraqi
government who by the way is not
hesitated to send their troops over to
recover the settlements Iraqi forces
sweep into Kirkuk checking Kurdish
independence drive so why is this
territory so valuable
well that's because Kirkuk is the
province that contains the most oil in
Kurdistan in fact it's been estimated
that around 10 percent of all Iraqi oil
reserves are concentrated here in Kirkuk
and nobody wants to let go
[Music]
in 2007 a referendum it should have been
conducted in order to incorporate or not
the autonomous region of Kurdistan but
the voting they never took place so when
the Peshmerga occupied the city in order
to protect it from Islamic state since
the Iraqi army had literally run away
the Kurd government had facto annex the
territory so with these conditions and
with the constant negotiations between
Baghdad and Erbil lands with a growing
disconnect between both territories they
eventually got the referendum this is
the first time in history that the
people of Kurdistan will freely decide
their future after that we will start
talks with Baghdad to reach an agreement
over borders water and oil mr. Barzani
president of Iraqi Kurdistan now the
governments of Iraq opposed this
referendum in every way and the
Constitutional Court of Iraq even
outlawed it Parliament asked for many
things including the withdrawal of
diplomatic representation in Erbil they
bought a closed gym and even army
deployments in Kirkuk there was also the
prosecution of organizers of the
referendum and of course Parliament
tried their best to remain in control of
all of the oil but even with this kind
of action by the Iraqi government the
Kurds they didn't really care
and that's only logical because despite
the progress of the Iraqi army the risk
for Kurdistan is probably not in Iraq
but rather with the international
community
you see Turkey and Iran they don't even
want to hear about an independent
Kurdistan that's because they might give
the Kurds in their territories the idea
that they can replicate this success
Turkey for instance has been a war with
the Kurds for decades but that's a story
for another day the thing is that these
countries have allied with Iraq in order
to defy the referendum Turkey's military
has confirmed that Turkey and Iraq will
conduct joint military drills in Turkey
along an area bordering Iraq
semi-autonomous Kurdish region Iran's
semi official is na news agency reported
on Sunday that the Supreme National
Security Council closed Iranian airspace
to the Iraqi Kurdish area at the request
of the central government in Baghdad and
no it's not just about the possibility
of conflicts after all this is likely to
be the result of fear tactics which are
very usual in this kind of situation and
they rarely work by the way remember
Kurdistan is a close ally of the USA and
they have an experienced and
well-trained army no the bigger issue
here might be that Kurdistan they need
their neighbors this territory its
landlocked and they are very dependent
on Turkey both in order to export their
oil then to import anything that they
might need so a trade blockade it would
be a serious threat for this territory
the kr G's economy depends on one
pipeline that sells oil to international
markets and that pipeline goes through
Turkey you shut down that pipeline you
choke the Kurdish economy Bilal Wahab
analyst at the Washington Institute for
Near East policy but there is more to it
than just their neighbors nobody wants
anymore tension with this part of the
world so internationally speaking that
referendum didn't get much support the
US has opposed it and Antonio Guterres
Secretary General of the UN has
described it as dangerous and
potentially disruptive and today Israel
is the only country that supports
independence so this might mean the
future is not looking very good right
well wait just a second because despite
all of this it is very likely the
Kurdistan will achieve independence you
know or later
[Music]
the reasons for a new country Iraqi
Kurdistan it's got many issues however
they have managed you become the region
that functions the best in Iraq they are
the safest and wealthiest area I've been
to Iraqi Kurdistan a number of times
it's safer than Kansas if you're coming
from Baghdad or Mosul it's practically
Switzerland Michael J Totten American
journalist check this out
in 2014 before the is offensive this
region was turning into the most
relevant financial and tourist spot in
Iraq an oasis from any businessman both
local and foreign skyscrapers smalls and
mansions were spreading like mushrooms
after the rain that was until war broke
out in Iraq against the Islamic state
then most of this development it simply
had to stop now after an awful few years
of war in 2017 the numbers are bouncing
back and do you remember that this area
is oil-rich some estimations calculate
the oil reserves of Kurdistan at forty
five billion barrels but this in two
words
Kurdistan would be among the 15 oil
richest countries on earth and this is
in a country with little more than five
million inhabitants but there's still so
much more Iraq's Kurdistan is quite
business-friendly indeed they like
private initiatives something uncommon
in this part of the globe taxes are also
attractive and bureaucracy is not
excessive either unfortunately though
there is still plenty of corruption the
Kurdistan government will do its best to
help the private sector and have them
invest here I invite all local and
foreign investors here to take advantage
of our laws and offers and invest
Massoud Barzani president of Iraqi
Kurdistan the thing is that this region
has enough going for it to make
Kurdistan a prosperous country their
fertile lands high levels of safety and
natural resources further their
geographical location is beneficial
it's a place between Turkey Iran and
Iraq but on top of all of that this new
country it's only well there the Kurd
people and especially Araki Kurds have
been supported for tax with chemical
weapons and have suffered all sorts of
social engineering in order to strangle
their culture and now they have an
opportunity to build their own country
further the rest of us could also
benefit from a more moderate prosperous
and free country than the ones around it
in the Middle East would certainly be
better for it so now we've got to
consider the problems in Iraq iike
I mean first of all are there any well
yes absolutely but that's no excuse to
not make this new country happen first
because these problems exist now within
still being a part of Iraq and second
because they are less serious than the
ones in the rest of the country so what
about corruption yes it's totally
Varun's is there oil dependency also yes
and what about debt well yes there is
that too but this is totally normal in
this part of the world the rest of Iraq
is in a much worse situation well anyway
we just wish that Baghdad's a response
does not turn the situation into a
military conflict that would be a
terrible scenario for everyone
indeed it would be a situation where
political interests prevail above the
interests of the people but now it's
time for your opinion do you support the
idea of the independence of Kurdistan
well do you leave your answer in the
comments below as well as in this survey
and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for brand new videos every
Monday and Thursday also do not forget
to check out our friends at the
reconsider Media podcast they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not
mine and as always thank you for
watching so you're still here still
watching this video maybe you just let
it run and you're not actually there
anymore whatever the case if you're
listening to this I think you should go
check out my new channel it's called bio
graphics it is biographies of notable
historic figures as well as present-day
people and give you some examples we got
the Queen of England Vladimir Putin
there's just two people on the world
sagittal Scott Elon Musk coming up
arnold schwarzenegger we even the first
serial killer HH h hans maybe just HH
holmes we look at all sorts of people
longer form about 20 minutes long diving
into the story of their lives in a
similar style to this it's by a graphics
if you like this channel if you like my
other stuff you're gonna like this as
well by a' graphics there is a link in
the description below do go check it out
and please do subscribe